[Music]
okay Hey ladies and ladies and gentlemen
it's me Jake I think I know what episode
this is its episode 197 so how about
that that's nice that's nice and I'm
here with my guest my traveling partner
on this southern tour which you've
missed which I told you about many times
but but it's not completely over i still
got nashville tomorrow night but I you
buy that by this time might be too late
for that but it's Wednesday februari
I'll wait I should turn on some music to
play that underneath yes Hey ladies and
gentlemen Wednesday March or thursday
mark 16th I'm going to be in Nashville
attains ok so now you know that and then
if you would like I'm going to be in
lincoln city oregon on the first week
weekend in April April haste I'm going
to be down in Boca Raton I got to put
those days on my website Jake this calm
so you can check those out if you want
to come and see me live which is what I
hope will happen and I've had some great
time at these shows during the southern
tour I've been in Denver I've been in
Minneapolis I've been in well I didn't
make Charlotte we had to cancel that
because of weather this whole blizzard
situation so apologies to my Charlotte
fans who bought tickets and I couldn't
do that show because I couldn't get into
town because it's a blizzard and the
next night though I was in Atlanta and
then birmingham tonight we did
huntsville it's been a pretty fun trip
and I'm traveling with my good friend
Jeff Tate who has been on the podcast
before I can't remember what episode
that is do you remember Jeff I don't
remember I don't know if I was on yours
I think you were on my really I just
mentors I guess this year's podcast yet
oh well it's good to be here yeah with
you on my part thanks for having me on
yours and this is the viewer you were a
get for me and to get you on my pocket
I get and to get me on your podcast is
you're just like doing me a favor I
don't know but oh I do i do I don't know
about that I don't I don't I think
you're being hard on yourself that's
what we do right like that's how I p.m.
that's how I'm funny low low self-esteem
if it wasn't that I would never get laid
if it wasn't for low self-esteem in fact
I'm ready to admit right now because
I've had two drinks after the show that
my wife may have made a mistake she did
but it's too late I've already got a kid
with her and I've locked her in that
that is too late yeah I've done she's
from New Zealand they get her an
administration she would have to leave
the country probably she's locked in you
have heard this is all written in pen no
she's not one of the terrorists she's
not one of us she's not on a watch list
she's on my watch list no I don't think
she's not watch list she's just she was
she's from somewhere else well she's an
American citizen now okay double check
can I see your ID yeah I'm thinking
about it other words no that's okay it
was just that was actually a joke so
we've had a fun little tour so far so
far we've got one night we're driving to
well tomorrow morning we're going to
wake up in Huntsville after a great show
tonight it was really fun in Huntsville
tonight yeah it's not rocket science but
the audience is rocket scientists here
in Huntsville AL level some of them yeah
not all of them some of them were baby
birds that needed to be fed the punch
lines but some of a rocket science yeah
I'm not trying to hurt anybody's
feelings I want people to feel good
about themselves especially if they paid
for a ticket and came out to see a show
don't you yeah yeah but this thing about
saying that is not one person but listen
to this good like I already talked about
me they're all gonna be like yeah I was
one of the smart ones yeah yo buddy you
can't be like you know what everybody is
the show that I was super-attractive
except for like there's like a handful
and really ugly people you could say
that because nobody is gonna be like
wait a second I think you're right yeah
so everybody you're the smart ones
obviously
talking about you yes the dummies don't
listen to this podcast there's too many
buttons to click between looking at your
phone in getting this to play there's
like two or three things you have it may
be harder to listen to this than it is
to record it it is definitely for me
I've had to do nothing no I've had to
explain it so many people how to
download a podcast to have them say look
it's not worth my time I guess so
congratulations high-five yourself if
you're even this bar down the road
because you may be you may already be a
rocket scientist anyway I didn't know
that Huntsville I thought it was always
NASA in Florida right and then Houston
yeah everybody knows about Mission
Control but a lot of the space program
is centered right here out of Huntsville
I had no idea yeah I didn't know that
either there's a space and I knew that
there was a space in rocketry Museum
here because I had been there as a kid
because i grew up we lived in nashville
for a little while when i was a kid so
i've been to this museum twice as a
child a child and a young adult and now
i'm looking forward to tomorrow morning
we're going to be going to the
huntsville space and Robert Reed museum
and then we're going to be doing we're
going to be talking about it afterwards
on your podcast we at gold it's now
called jeff has mashed potato I
apologize for the hesitate smash podcast
oh and that is that how you search on
iTunes port even his type in Jeff hey
it'll come up yeah and good luck with
that amigo te 0 FF and there may be some
people out there who don't even know
that that's an alternative spelling for
Jeff now and even when they do find out
they still refuse to believe it for a
little while I tell you hello it's true
it's not some made-up things my show you
my ID no you got mad cuz I know I know I
want to believe me I'm going to check
all your papers before this is over but
GE 0 FF taste yeah I try I was and
what's called afternoon when you did it
it was called afternoon everybody
because I was trying to make a podcast
only about cheers and then that became
why couldn't you still call it afternoon
everybody when you changed it because I
started making a lot of different types
of podcast where
with different like themes and formats
or whatever and I was putting them all
under the same so now do you have a lot
of different podcasts with different
names I have the one like under jeff
cage match broadcast so it's like a
network and then there are they all the
same feed them yeah it's all the same
speed but it's all it's all me they're
all my podcast but there's like there
was no if they subscribe to just yet mud
oh yeah mash pocket an ash podcast oh
they'll get all of them all of them yeah
there's one I may be like oh I got a
wife and I know what I don't know why
didn't you just should have had
subgenres inside of the genre yeah I try
it was always named Jeff takes mad no no
it was it was when okay lurid it was
only afternoon everybody and only about
cheers as much as it could be and now
afternoon everybody is just one of the
show's was offered on the Jeff take my
spark a so network if I understood what
you were talking about I would feel like
I could help explain it to the people
who are listening now well but instead
since I don't I just have to apologize
to everyone listening and to say if
you'd like to hear us talk about our
post rocket museum yeah conversation
going to mass podcast oh and best of
luck but right now wait it out okay
nobody's links you could react it'll be
it won't it's not you're making it
complicated though because it does it
isn't what one of the problems what I'm
gonna grab Dominic down like that
episode and I'm going to put it out
online but after yours is always on this
because I can't be sure that the people
who are listening to my podcasts are
really rocket scientist I think they
might not be although i do anything for
people to live in a minor geniuses oh
you're give the people listen to yours
when we're on yours tomorrow and trying
to explain how to go back track and see
the prequel to that it's going to be
equally complicated but that's what you
can do but what i'm saying is i may just
i may just simulcast your podcast I
wanted a yeah you should do but you
should but you should go check out just
ate what is this jen smash podcast the
mad mashed potato but you change and
just like be off yeah but don't ever bet
your one Jake I get to say that one time
and that was it because we're friends
who've been
driving in a car yeah and today I didn't
I didn't know that was going to be so
touchy I'm sorry I did that I have no I
haven't stopped smiling the whole time
but there is something there there is so
like the 11 year old memories that kind
of it gets riled up when I hear it said
wrong p.m. because you have a lot of
parents obviously knew they would name
you Jeff and you thought you were in
offshore and they did you and then when
you had to go to school and have
expelled the worst was when teachers
would do it because we move so much that
there was always there was that day when
I was going to have to go into class for
the first time and the teacher was going
to read my name off the roll call sheet
and it was just pins and needles until
till the teaser shot every run to see if
she said it right or wrong at and if she
said it wrong 7 I was [ __ ] the rest of
the time i was at that's cool and where
did where did that spelling of Jeff come
from Yuma England England oh do you mean
like the name etymology of the word what
I got no one it's filled with the G it
comes from England but why yeah how did
you get it ok this is a not to my
parents knew there were naming me Jeff
but not until after I was born they
thought how much after well like that
day but they did not have they thought I
was going to be a girl as I was gonna be
named Veronica because my dad's name is
Ron thank God that didn't happen
Veronica yeah that in a second oh I feel
like you've already made a mistake by
telling people that now I've done up
told I've said it before does anyone
call you Veronica's now I Oliver would
make you mad if I called you Veronica
from that from now on I feel like this
is a business at all fair conversation
yeah no you're right okay I'm not going
to call you Veronica that was wrong but
if someone comes up to you to you after
a show and said hey I heard you want to
Jake this podcast if someone calls me
Veronica now I will know it's because of
this podcast and I'm ready absolutely
delighted okay but you've got to do with
a smile and immediately out your hand up
Oh high five during the show either no
no don't say we're like a lie but no
hanging there's no heckling of the
performers or you will be asked to leave
get a high five bring an interpreter and
whisper how's it going Veronica how's
the hell now although this is from this
is a this is from Jake podcast okay and
we'll give you a nickname on mine to
save anybody in what happened yeah we're
going by lady names this yes I got born
a dude and that my dad there was a
parent Lee the story goes there was a
guy on the radio who had his name and
they thought well that's interesting so
they gave me this man Jeff yeah with a
gene really you got to find a guy on the
radio named Jeff and everybody knows it
Jeff but with a G know so they found
that and then how did they know his his
was filled with the g he was on the
radio so they don't lose another
billboard ok right this was back when
radio with Kimball 870 and yes Angeles
not like now now podcaster King
apologize okay now that now there is no
Kane the kingdom has shattered yeah it's
split into get systems it's browse more
keep them chat it's chaos chaos but I
said ciao I is a little bit of a deal
yeah sure I saw when you said that I
thought that was one of those times were
like you were smarter than me and I
wasn't going to haul it out how many
times does that happen this trip that's
how many times of highly how many times
have I just lasted something and then
tried to move on every time I do that
it's because I'm like by probably just
don't know what that means I did that a
couple times tonight while we were
watching de cariño who is opening for
lavell Crawford I didn't understand all
the choke there was a couple of Joe's
where I couldn't there was something the
muffled his voice the Senate ism was a
little messed up yeah man is a little
like a tonal yeah so after our show
there was another show with lavell
Crawford and his opening act was
Lee nice guy attic area who's all who
was also funny but I was just the sound
system with more anyway I have filled it
he's got a pretty high success rate
because the the the times I understood
the whole joke I laughed yeah I thought
he was at times I didn't laugh word just
because I had gotten lost somewhere on
the way but so let's get back to your
parents and Jeff and then let's get on
to Tom Petty okay I already like the way
to go and I know all these answers yeah
I don't want it I'm not trying to got
you this isn't a gotcha podcast good
because I don't know the names of all
the newspapers i've read i just read so
many everyday so many newspapers that
was the big gotcha moment 2008 was the
follow-up question to i read a lot of
newspapers and the follower pleasure was
oh yeah which one when that was so
what's her name sarah palin right had
her she funny things that she read but
let's get back to Jeff so your parents
they like that name because it was DJ
they named you Jeff mm-hmm and that was
that that was that I never thought to
google it love the couldn't but also we
were still a couple years away from
queens right releasing albums right and
other than some other day yeah what
about what about that radio Jeff take
whatever became of that kind of you oh I
don't think he had the same last name as
me oh he his first man in the disco
whatever happened to that radio chip it
has never once occurred to me to look
him up Oh see you crushed him he's
defeated yeah I've almost caught up to
the one from Queens ranked really in
Google yeah well i am now did you you no
longer have to type comedy or comedian
uh with my name to give me to show up on
the first page that's nice so like I
think I like I show like second like I
think his website and then my website or
might be you're listening to this right
now you could do my friend Jeff Tate a
favor by googling geoff tate and then
clicking on the comedian one yeah I
whether that should I
just another clown so click on that one
just another know but don't want a booty
like if you want to push him down in the
search results I think you got a google
I just want to make sure that they don't
google my name is insane Jeff Tate calm
is me because that's not me no but one
day will that guy's going to blow
himself out that guy it's not even his
it's a it's a fan site oh it's not even
Queen's right that's how big they are
they don't even do their own podcast
he's not like years not even in Queens
Reich anymore what's he doing now he's
touring was his own bang which i think
is called operation mindcrime which was
the name of a Queen's reggae album do
you think he knows what you're doing
yeah I'm sure of it that's good he isn't
I've been on the I've talked to him
before I've met him a couple times I was
all I did I have done interviews I did a
45-minute interview with a radio show in
long island the guy hope this guy's some
dude hosted a metal show in long island
and he sent me a Facebook message and
was like right after the band broke up
and there was all that because he
thought you with me oh god oh yeah and
that happened that happened a lot it
used to have it on my expense all the
time then it then the it hasn't happened
in a couple years and I think that but I
would like to i would like to hear Jeff
Tate Jeff state versus Jeff Tate on some
of political issues of the day oh boy
this guy he drives me crazy because his
his name is spelled like my GE 0 FF but
his first name is Geoffrey with a jay
jay eff are you why she doesn't even
have to have the GE 0 FF part I have to
have it you have to have it because it's
so new births triptych is my name is and
I could I could switch it to je ever
when I first uh when I first did don't
do that like when I did comedy when I
did live at Gotham or something duh Dave
wrath uh-huh comedy manager yeah comedy
comedy manager Dave wrath a guy who has
Moses Lee knows what he's doing yeah
yeah we for sure does and he's probably
like he's probably not wrong either cuz
back then like it probably would have
benefited me to change my book it still
buddy II OBE is until today yeah yeah d
EO v just like juggs like he understands
the pitfalls of having a difficult name
to spell and he wasn't wrong I just wear
this build wa ra th isn't it he he was
probably right it would have been easier
and that was like two thousand eight you
me but I just felt like it was such a
betrayal of like because I your parents
and you know about that and your
identity I felt like if I was going to
be a comedian the reason I'm a comedian
like one of the main reasons is because
of this may I said Nene mad a lot too
really yeah having to go moving all the
time and having to water did you a favor
no cuz who once the who wants to do this
really no I know I'm loving it are you
any good are you saying what are you
talking about I've been a totally fun
couple of days yeah yeah Jake I've been
doing comedy for 15 right so we found a
million years humbled at it we've had a
great every time I see you I have a
great day so I have had what is that 14
great days well look Sarge a giant
somebody new that said but for me if
that's a huge compliment so thank you
well you up soz i mean don't get don't
get a big head so no I don't know we
laid my bed but I've had plenty of it
I've had my share of comeuppance I feel
like I'm trying to I'm trying to have a
good time and create a good time and I'm
wetter and that's what the shows are
well I'm Way better at it now than I was
even a couple years ago Mike being
positive and seeing the positive side of
it but yeah I mean there are times when
like I wanted to be a pilot when I was
in high school like what kind of
pleasant I wanted to be an Air Force
pilot because it was the closest thing
to being it was like the real life
version of being
like in Star Wars dude we're going
there's a ways I know I know ill
astronaut museum tomorrow and I but I
feel like if my name was spelled ur to
be careful my name is spelled with a J
oh I feel like I might have been a you
might have been upon it I'm movin like I
say I think that you you just divide in
this H I J so you were three letters
away from being upon oh yeah and I know
and who knows I mean I mean maybe if I'm
a pilot I get to meet Sinbad but for
sure as a comedian I did is that one of
the highlights your career is getting
the meats in that I know you like him I
like yeah quite and respect force in bed
there's a I'm i honest-to-god houseguest
is one of the movies I've seen the most
when I was going to make a list of the
10 minute you've seen that before you
met sin debt so yeah so many times I
thought before I met some guys I'm
probably seeing that movie a hundred
times I see the weekend I've seen every
time I can really get it who else is in
houseguest besides in bed still Harlan
grace the Lord is great it's the zany is
dude and the width of a gator riot who
knows what would have happened if his
wife had not killed him [ __ ] chef if
I don't like to curse why do I should
take that back i do enjoy curse I don't
yeah I don't like the curse when it's
appropriate and when you talk about Phil
Hartman dying being [ __ ] fat that is
appropriate so I don't care for that man
I like it when it does you only have a
little funny so houseguest still stands
up still stands up I don't know if
everybody was viewing you like it I
watched like I watch it again a couple
months ago it makes me laugh it just you
it's just the way some bad funny is a
good way to be funny I think to me he
knows what you wanted to say boy does he
like when you there are people that you
you may I mean I'm sure I'm sure it's
happening here you've met like in your
career you've you've met a lot of people
that you wanted to make probably at a
lot of people that you looked up to
you've probably met people you were
apprehensive to me because you weren't
and I'm sure that it's gone both ways
where ya was in that or everybody
everyone out I've run into sin bet he
has been very nice and you had a very
positive experience meetings in bed I I
have never met I don't think I've ever
met anybody as good at being what you
wanted them but like what I wanted it
like Sinbad is duty idea like you know
like we have to take present company
excluded present company I feel like I'm
doing a pretty good job no no you listen
you're like you're okay I feel like
there's no way I meant that as a tune I
don't know I know but I like I want to
like I do think it is will be helpful to
explain what I made when I meet when I
met you you were how I thought you'd be
from the way I saw you on TV right but
you hadn't seen anything that I had done
a hundred times the way go ahead Sinbad
Sinbad didn't the waste in that is on
his phantom specials and tell the shore
you something you told the other night
when you you stayed over you are on
Comedy Festival you knew thats in bed
was on the same festival do you want to
show the dagger everybody loves
everybody you requested to stay an extra
day you asked the festival organizers if
they could get you a hotel room you
would pay for a ticket they comped all
that stuff so you go to that every day
oh you go to the show then what happens
the lady the government dissidia took me
in the back to meet him like an hour
before the show and he saw my badge that
I was a comedian and I was the only
other because my it was Michael Morris
festival and Michael Moore was going to
introduce them like so there wasn't even
a there wasn't even like a host huh it
was like Michael just went out talk for
a minute to the to the people like
thanking them perfect festival again you
know another year of a grape festival
here's our big you know the closing act
us in bed and so for an hour we're in
the back he's meeting day before the
ship before that now we rewind before
the show he's lined up they have all
like the big hoity-toity festival
sponsors the fancy rich folks and he is
killing my keep the politician yeah he's
talking everybody making friends acts
kind aids kind of like the way people
describe when they like would meet Bill
Clinton when they're like oh you didn't
go like this guy's charismatic he always
liked you when the I he he seems like
he's talking so you're in line to meet
Sinbad you I wasn't in line as soon as
he's a it was like it was almost like
the office and he's doing he's doing a
show for the sponsors in the back he has
shaking hands or whatever and as soon as
you see like he sees me on the side sees
that I'm a comic and then now I'm next
to him like I'm his running mate I am
not part of the crowd now I'm part of
the committee he it was like oh now now
there's two comedians yeah and that's
pretty nice that's a that's a really
nice story I don't anybody who wants to
say something bad about Sinbad should
listen to that story and check
themselves because that is a quality
person nobody say anything about my
mattifies yet I love somebody so much he
got divorce from his wife but he didn't
want to be divorced so we bought a house
in the same neighborhood like I'm like
down the street and like won her back
and now his kids live in that house and
his wife got remarried and living there
original huh that's why he that's why he
was a out of the public eye for a lot of
the 2,000 well was he decided he would
rather get it would rather get his
marriage back together and then he comes
back and he just would let Leslie funny
he did two hours on stage I didn't get
up to smoke I didn't get up to stretch I
didn't I don't watch two hours of
stand-up sense yeah it's a lot it's hard
to do testimonial go see sin bet it's
great that's such a nice story it's
always nice to hear somebody tell a good
story about about somebody else where
where it's rewarding when you meet
somebody in and you really enjoy them to
material I didn't know the bent yeah
well I haven't seen since bad stand up
that often but you know like I was
telling you in the car today he had kind
of gotten this weird I think people were
really jealous of him when he for
got famous and he's been nothing but
nice to me so it was really great to
hear that story I think either glad you
told it again now and I think yeah have
you heard the government Donald sorry
about somebody know they did like are
you allowed to tell nor McDonald story I
just said it was more McDonald so again
no I'm just saying yeah his story is
that was like me saying are you sure you
want to tell this where should people
just google it her no I don't know I
mean I don't even remember I don't even
know this i might be telling us i might
be out of turn here that gets a true
story i know it but i don't know that i
heard it from normal i don't remember
okay well let's say there's a normally
an old story about sin bed no this is a
good story like they do like they're
doing like just for my officers on them
and the day of their big guy like the
big dresser lecture of module Sinbad's
gotta go buy some stock so he takes
normies like come on we'll buy some
socks and norms on nervous and like
meticulously going over it said it's
like okay i'll go with some but so
somebody goes of my socks comes back
they go on that night to do the show
simbad does his entire like five minutes
showcase that on buying those socks and
just murders and going on the bag you
spent all day just got wrenched trying
to hear meticulously pieces together and
soon as i get into that was fun enough
begin socks yeah he's natural Sinbad's
natural he sees supernatural
supernatural hey talk about tom petty
you love Tom Petty Tom patty I'm like
I'm scared to meet Tom Petty because
there's a they say never meet your
heroes I've had a good I've had good
luck so far and one and one of my heroes
was Mark married and he made a pike the
first two years of his podcast was in
dis apologizing to people that he met
who he was there Yura huh and when I and
he was my life I've had good luck and I
don't want it to like a rather not meet
Tom Petty then have it run out with Tom
Petty like just like have him be the one
that I would love it if you met Tom
Petty because you like I know he's got
to
fans I know he's a super famous musician
I don't want to take anything away from
him but he has never been like I never
met anybody who loved Tom Petty the way
you do no I have any other talk about it
how did you first get into it it was I
was in high school and I heard Mary
Jane's last night and it was immediately
better than all of the Christian rock
and roll I had been previously allowed
to listen to him because your dad's a
minister so my dad's a minister here and
I her marriage as last dance and decided
like I was really into that song and I
until I got like while the wild flowers
album and the greatest hits or whatever
but I had never listened to rock and
roll at all so I I knew better than to
be like well this one's going to be my
favorite the first one I ever heard as I
didn't listen to everything on the radio
for two years really was the first girl
i had sex with that's who I wanted to
marry yeah pretty great yeah I mean
that's the way it's supposed to be
you're not supposed to listen to secular
music until you're ready to choose your
favorite band and without having what we
had was everybody looking in the line
work Tom Petty oh just like church ends
and stuff like music was never really
around our house and so how did you hear
Tom Petty even as am i it was 15 so the
first time the first time in my life
somebody that was a peer had their own
car and who was it my buck buck robeson
he had a 79 buick lesabre it was awesome
then he turned left on red and [ __ ]
got hit by a semi truck he's dead man
nice buck is fine that's that's how dope
of 79 buick lesabre is it took a hit
from a semi truck running a red light
and him and him and Josh how's ur walked
away from it wow how long was that after
you've heard Tom Petty I was like I was
a few years after I bug has x hard for
most eyes so buck which is whoops buck
Sadie had come for a ride my card check
now he's taking me home after back after
like
basketball practice or something like we
lived in the same we went to Cincinnati
Christian what grade 10 and so this is
like private school in Cincinnati that
was a going home from basketball yeah
don't I mean don't get all the when I
say private school don't start picturing
it's a school that you go to if you got
expelled we wish you a naughty kids now
not with you could also go you could go
for free of your father was a minister
mm-hm so there's a bunch of preacher
kids and then a budget kids that have
been expelled from various public
schools around the city because it was
super he didn't cause anything to go on
so Lucky's are lucky you being a
preacher's kid you get to go to school
with all the kind of oh yeah it don't
like it you naughty kids like it might
as well have been to be there was any
way I thought it was bucket juvie guy
now buck was buck was his parents were
religious his mom was I guess and so
he's driving you home from basketball
practice what's he saying I know that is
like you kind of remember no I don't
remember him saying anything because I
didn't really I knew better than to
advertise the fact that I had never
listened to any of this like rock n roll
so we probably he just put it on yeah he
just turned on no video turned on the
car the radio station was playing
commercials and when it came back from
commercials that played mary janes lat
back oh so he wasn't into tom petty and
i was just a raffle at moma gray dia and
i and i remember that i remember hearing
that and bit and being like this is
whatever this is this is better and then
I then I just listen to the radio and it
was in that period of time I I like what
year are we talking 93like the guy
that's my best friend still I remember
asking like figuring out like right
around it was when I figured out that I
could listen to music without getting in
trouble because there were ways to do it
without my parents
out headphones cassette tapes other
people's cars like that SSH so we have
Walkman you could have bought a Walkman
I'm sure yeah yeah but there was before
that I debt I didn't buy a Walkman
because there was no reason to because I
didn't know anything and it you know you
think anything to please others anything
worth going through though you got into
him listening to the radio and then did
you was there anybody else that you
liked at that same time oh man at that
time I like to everything I think I i
mean i was i got i got really into
Aerosmith because they were in and
they're not there they were like no you
can't ever a way in world to you can't
argue you can argue with though arrows
but I was in two I will enter the wrong
half of it I was in fact that everyone
it's like here's a hard stance I'm going
to take there's a real heartache funny I
think Sammy Hagar is a better singer
than David Lee Roth you I think over the
rods might be a better frontman but I'm
not going to see Jesus Christ Superstar
I want to hear a bunch of song some good
I don't need a [ __ ] I don't need a
guide at top hat and a cane dancing
around a sage David Lee Roth at New not
been high on his own supply is what
you're saying oh yeah just I think that
there are these there are these like
universally accepted ideas about
rock'n'roll beds that are if you really
think about it they're just not there
just not correct the same you hang our
songs are better the okay what is a
great Sammy Hagar sewing that you would
compare to a great David Lee rolling
stone well first of all we got to figure
out what it's great David Lee Roth song
is beautiful girls I mean well that's
fine it's a different I mean they're
different kinds of their different kinds
of good David Lee Roth can be more fun
with Sam you know there's a better
singer all right the prompt album they
get a grip I love them like the late the
that after Aerosmith broke up there's
like a demarcation line and heiress was
the first five or six albums were really
wanting Roland
no I'm talking about Arizona you
confusing me a little bit because David
Lee Rosen what they have us they have a
similar trajectory okay first five or
six thousand deniro sins broke up
because they were all [ __ ] up on drugs
and stuff and then they all went they
would like a sober and then they got
back together like 87 and that's when
they started making like the rag doll
and those kind of like more 80s Stephen
Tong fo Zeppelin drugs yeah you had the
whole bandwidth but didn't they all got
clean and then they made let's take Tom
Petty I love it an elevator and like all
that stuff like really poppy like
heavily produced up that tends to get
the bad rap that's the true Aerosmith
fans are only fans up through like the
before days before they burrow this is a
little too deep for me so but I what I'm
saying is I like the bad halves of both
of those bands when did you want to be a
pilot was that before or after you found
out about Tom Petty that was mostly
before I really finding about about Tom
Petty and stuff like kind of his wife
other the idea of doing something else
without knowing what it would be but the
idea of not being a pilot and seeing
what else was around i'd started to i
think i think finding the tom petty was
when i started to think maybe i don't
know enough to make any actual decisions
yet Wow tell Betty put you in your place
yeah well I thought you know like from
the information that I had which was
incomplete at best inaccurate and in
some cases too but best-case scenario
was at least incomplete I had ideas of
what I wanted to do with my life and how
I wanted my life to go and then I hear
like all of a sudden hearing Tom patios
like wait a second they told me that
there wasn't anything good over like
there and then what happened after that
how did your life change what did you
would you decide you wanted to do X
company I'm as good as i was telling to
go to college and stuff but
I ended I've not even doing that you
didn't go to coach now for nah not
really i think i have enough i kind of i
tried to add this up a couple weeks ago
somebody else has been the same question
a couple weeks ago i think i have have
almost enough credits to be a sophomore
like i have almost done where some sin
claire Community College and Dayton I
got a couple credits and then Randall
Walters which was which into a UC UC
blue ash is what it's called now I guess
university of cincinnati in blue ash I
did too full i think i got like 30
credit hours from there and then did you
you bailed out of college and went is
that when you started to do calmly I
started doing Santa when I was going to
when I was like when I a few months I've
had to I was doing caught going to
college full time mm-hmm 23 years
friends and then i do then i kept going
to college and kept doing a open mics
and stuff and then kind of figured that
like I liked this better yeah and that I
mean I was going to be a journalist
that's what I was majoring in so but I
was doing that to phuong don't yeah but
now it turns out you don't need a degree
to be a journalist you don't yeah I
don't think you did agree to do anything
anymore but well maybe well maybe our
bolivia huntsville if you want to be
playing in rockets to go into space so
how long you been doing stand-up now i
think it's i think it's 15 years and
what advice would you give a young
person who had grown up in a religious
environment and was just hearing their
version of Tom Petty for the first time
and trying to decide how to change their
life
there's no there's no way to not shove
it like this was a years-long like in
that situation you got a years-long but
the toilet somebody who's just kind of
had their mind blown and had you know
the world is flipped and opened up for
them because that's what it seems like
you were saying happen to you yeah yeah
I would say if that if that happens that
means that uh you need to go out and
find where you've missed some of you've
missed I don't know I don't know exactly
what that is I wouldn't know tell us
about for yourself what what what else
did you find that you'd miss besides
popular music and company I mean
everything I missed so much my two
favorite things are Tom Petty and the
movies and I wasn't allowed to see I
wasn't allowed to see any movies really
huh noting that was rated R and then now
there's nothing better than a rated r
movie really nothing's better than that
but so I mean as far as what I mean as
far as movies go miss accommodate is
rated R especially by the time period
that I'm talking about yeah art and we
could be swearing you could really do
some naughty stuff there was much more
of a clear line then then now now I
can't always tell with what's rated R
most rated PG can you think you know no
because it's all like pg-13 now just
means the person got was horribly
murdered just all scream Oh or was
horribly murdered on screen put all the
blood and whatever the wood of half a
damn it but fact that happened back then
what good are mean to you when you say
that oh it would just be like kingpin
was rated R like that movie is just
hilarious yeah and it is like every like
every comedy there's always there's very
rarely is there a comedy that doesn't
have like one thing i don't like oh
don't dumb and dumber has that same
where Jack I know yeah I have to use the
restroom
I would have left just as hard a time
movie without that name and there's the
thing was a landlady and kingpin is
disgusting is that the one where he says
I think I tore my sack he that is that's
that movie yeah but that's a different
machine that's a different thing that I
mean there are so many funny lines in
that movie that my current funding my
current favorite line from that movie is
a Woody Harrelson is leaving his shitty
apartment at the beginning and there's
two old guys just sitting there folding
chairs in front of the building and he
goes how's life and one of the old guys
just mutters taken forever it's I hadn't
seen it the first however many times i
was i'm going to be 20 years i watch
that movie i didn't notice that what's
your favorite movie right now because it
was over and over it's always Fletch I
know much much no matter what Fletch
really skills yeah that's so long ago
yeah I probably seems like the most of
any movie i watch Fletch i watch The Big
Lebowski I watched die hard yet I get
you on die hard this is the big lebowski
I haven't seen that for a while and I
want to see that again i distill it that
Canyon beliefs which could still work I
just like I like everything about funny
like the music like a Chevy Chase of the
absolute maybe tomorrow we watch close
oh yeah he was he well that's why i
watch the Davis oh to be perfect it's
the perfect character for him because
he's he's not like suave or whatever but
he's not like he's not also like a boat
like he's a bozo in those vacation
movies yeah and he's very funny in the
vacation movies but I don't think he's a
bozo yeah and in Fletch like flesh is
just like they might as well as them
call that movie Chevak it just feels
like what a phase I hope something
that's very contemporary that to
recently come out tropic thunder tropic
thunder
that's still contemporary I mean yeah
yeah I don't mind I'm right here oh yeah
don't even if it's only nine years old
tropics but like i have i've asked I've
asked around and it is almost unanimous
the first time you see tropic thunder
that's the funniest movie but it's
pretty great it's pretty great I thought
three times the first week it came out
because I just and you can watch movies
over and over some some people can't do
that say it's hard time of it I mean I
didn't the third time made it so I
didn't watch it again for a little while
but I'll watch it now erase it like when
i say i watch a movie over and over I
can't fall asleep unless something's
plan how many times between between
showings like if you watched if you
watch tropic thunder last night would
you watch it again tonight yeah yeah how
long I could I cobaca probably watches
three times a year three times here if
you put it put it in maybe watch it fall
asleep maybe the next day skip ahead to
where closely watch another 20-30
minutes hours again let's talk about
what we're going to do tomorrow because
we're kind of coming into the home
stretch of this podcast we're going to
be doing your podcast tomorrow which is
saying jeff had jet head smashed by casa
Jeff take smash podcast oh we're going
to do that tomorrow after we've been to
the Huntsville space and rocketry Museum
and driven to Nashville and hot chicken
we're having hot chicken and you say
when you go to Nashville and you have
hot chicken what's the famous place the
famous places premises but we're not
doing that what I go to princes were
going to Hattie big Eddie piece all
right I've been to both Hattie B's is a
heady peas or beat bees with a big like
a boy MattyB isn't boy hmm hey
I just I did like that I like that check
out the princess is so hot alright so
we're going to have handy beats hot
chicken tomorrow we're looking forward
to going to the rocket 3 museum because
going to go to the other cluster are we
going to go to it we're going to buy one
we're going to eat it goo goo is the
resident weirdo cluster yeah googoo
clusters like store where you can watch
them being made to okay I'm in for that
I'm gonna buy a bunch of those is my
dad's favorite candy so I like to buy a
bunch and eat them in front of them show
who the dad is now you're a little bit
up on your dad I think you can I give
them a goo goo cluster I'll probably
give them a whole box of them and then
three days three days later I'll be like
here you should use your you should use
a walker wheels to get in the back and
then he'll be like you never do anything
for me now you should wait like like in
your act when he with you when you're
really sad he gives you a hug if your
hubby butter you should wait till he is
really sad men just hand him a goo goo
cluster oh man I we had dinner at the
olive garden because he wanted to go to
the olive like it was a ticklish for
Valentine's Day he want to take my mom
somewhere fancy so he came up with an
olive garden but he can't eat anything
really how come I don't know it's not he
just only ones like chicken fingers now
though he only likes chicken fingers he
can eat others yeah he can he knows not
like he has diabetes or something where
he's no no sir nothing he's allowed to
he just it just it's inconsistent what
he likes and doesn't like now and it
doesn't match up with what he used to
lie cannot like so he doesn't really
know yet and just because the last time
you went to the Olive Garden 10 years
ago he liked it that for sure doesn't
mean he's going to still like it just 10
years ago we would go to we would heal
you wet her and then what we went there
and then what happened I went to
chick-fil-a on my way and let him there
and bought a 12 pack of chicken others
so that and then I waited you bought it
a chicken nuggets at chick-fil-a yeah
and then I took the Box man in my jacket
pocket
soon as he did realize he didn't like
forgetting I'm a bold I gave him chicken
fingers like a baby he's like a kid
that's like a little kid he doesn't know
what he likes he's like a little kid
except a little kid I don't know exactly
what the difference is but a little bit
haha i do i think it may really know
very little note that will wreck i think
it's a little i honestly think it's
easier to reason with a kid I don't have
one so I understand your skepticism but
in my in my experience with other
people's kids and it might just be
because there are other people kids but
it is easier for it is easier to
convince a kid that what I'm saying is
not to [ __ ] their life up but uh huhs is
in their best interest then it is and
he's like with and he's with his wife
your mom yeah does she go to olive
garden with you yeah yeah it was a yeah
she had she liked it I mean we'll do
that because uh so he didn't like it and
then you gotta give him chicken fingers
while you and your mommy you're all
ignored yeah and my brother was her to
you but we all have my dad thinks my
brother there are times when he sings my
brother is the only one of the families
alike some because he's not like he's my
brother never tells him that he can't do
something anything that he thinks of me
and my mom are just out to [ __ ] ruin
his life what do you tell him that he
can't do I tell him that I tell him and
don't tell him that he can't do anything
I recommend that if you're going to walk
all that he can't walk the his back is
real [ __ ] up and that has made and has
been for a long time and so now it's a
combination of his back hurting and his
legs are really really weak so he
doesn't he doesn't have the strength to
walk and when he does walk it's real
hunched over so he's just he just needs
help walking yet he refuses to use up
his cane
Walker because he thinks it makes him
look old that is that is such a common
thing you know people that want to get
hearing aids because I think it makes
them look old or I so that's advice that
we can give ourselves like when you need
the Walker use the Walker I don't think
I would ever I don't think I'm I don't
think I'm that bang you don't know
because I give even if I mean if I can't
walk I'll [ __ ] i'll use the cane I
have seen but the main advice that I
take from that is I do when I'm at home
I do yoga when I'm not on the road I go
to yoga workout I get on the treadmill
as much as I can I want to hear about
yoga but is it I fee used it I'm going
to pause and we'll come right back ok
we're back so tell me about your yogurt
oh I am really I like I haven't done it
a lot and I just started like I just do
there's no bold out of the box with the
yogin I just went to the bathroom it
took me to you know I don't not that I'm
not bold about it I just don't have
anything this all I'm very bad at it but
I'm getting better and is how did you so
do take a class or do you have yeah
there's a glass of the as i joined the
community gym in my neighborhood this
Cincinnati recreation center has a nice
gender my neighborhood and they do yoga
three times a week can I get up there
when I can and do do what I can and try
to keep up and I get a little bit better
and all right you know if I just keep my
treat it the same way like I treat going
to therapy and sausage is like I do it
and I may not notice the difference
between this week and next week or
behind this week and two weeks from now
or you know maybe even you know but no
six months maybe I'm so just was bad but
eventually it's all about consistent if
you justified just keep doing it you got
all looking really good will get better
at it I like anything else I mean that's
man you guys for anything whenever
anybody says how do you become a
comedian I go start doing comedy and
then don't don't quit everything else
was noise like just do as long as you do
that eventually will be a community and
i guess like just keep going and so i'm
going to do that so that my i'm going to
instead of instead of accepting that at
some point i might have to use a walker
I'm going to do what I can now to not
end it up like that like but if you
notice that a walker was helping you you
would you would use it yeah I would use
it yeah okay because I don't have enough
vanity to not do yoga even though I'm
bad at it and he won't like he wouldn't
do that he did he wouldn't do it he
wouldn't do it says it was there every
other is back surgeries because he was
that at it he would quit doing that he
did like a lot of what a lot of what is
happening his basement like this is a
culmination of vanity it's him not this
isn't the first this is the first time
I've seen him not do what he's supposed
to do but it's interesting to me landed
because he's a minister so he was in the
position of telling other people advice
about how to live their life and he on
you could do that all day but he's
ignored some prefacing homeboy I mean I
hope they'll do so still tell you how to
much well doesn't he understand that
he's not he's disobeying some good if I
don't know he doesn't understand my yeah
because i was late I I get there I I
have empathy for him and I know I know
where it comes from I know it comes from
mike from his parents and the time they
grew up in and whatever but he is he's
really uh he's really only his only main
concern is himself and that is really
even when he was yeah a minister oh yeah
yeah yeah what was he concerned with
the most well the minister is a the
minister is the easiest position the the
easiest attainable position of power in
the community uh-huh is a job you can be
hired for and imagine if you just throw
that application to work a blockbuster
and getting that job meant that will
enjoy your devoted a certain faith yeah
yeah it's like when as the Christian
Church was a lot of it then we moved a
little Christian but in Minot
Presbyterian nut yeah they're in room I
don't not Presbyterian not Lutheran the
Christian Church sect that's the version
of Christianity really a church called
the Christian Church yeah this church of
christ church of god and just name it
was a young minister now he was a
seminary school which is again Mike if
you're just going to do something was
all made up and just make it up in the
beginning don't spend four years or
whatever right but but it's a real thing
he really did do that yeah he really did
he ever give you any good advice I mean
that sounds that sounds like I know that
mean he didn't there's nothing that a I
certainly don't have a well my daddy
always said at hand oh I got no you were
never in a situation where he offered
some advice to turned out to be good I'm
trying to remember and I'm afraid I'm
afraid did he get I'm gonna I'm gonna
say yes because it's a month em but you
can't remember but I can't remember it
and you remember any advice he gave
somebody else that really helped them
out now I wouldn't have ever heard it
probably like but there's no he doesnt
sit around and go I remember this one
time I was doing with this person yeah
now I remember
remember any conversations that I don't
know that he ever what advice would you
give him if you could give him advice
just but the advice I would give him is
it doesn't make me weak to say I don't
know that's good advice for everybody
saving it it doesn't make you weak it's
not a sign of weakness to say I don't
know it's not a kind of ignorant to say
I don't know to know that you don't know
something is find that it makes no
difference one way or the other to
pretend you know something when you
don't that makes you a fool they catch
you in full yeah so I mean I got and
Christians do that a lot they have a
hard time saying I don't know at least
the ones I grew up with I got tons of
the friends I got sent to the
principal's office a handful of times
for like what was deemed last for me
because I had expectations that the
teacher would know the answer and
instead of seeing able to say instead of
saying I don't know I got sent out of
class like out of bible class so that's
the Bible out as our teacher a question
of other Bible and when she didn't know
the answer she would send me to the
principal's office instead of thing I
don't know that a thing I think I know
frustrated that you have a hard question
yeah and it and it to her it was I was
showing her up and trying to undermine
the Bible or whatever but to me this was
a class in school where I would be
tested and the grades counted on my way
now the answer to when i asked the math
teacher a question he knew the [ __ ]
answer when i asked a Spanish teacher a
question he knew the answer whereas the
Bible teacher there were other questions
asked if she did know the answer she
would just answer it it's not like it
was just askin you I remember a question
that you asked that she doesn't know the
answer
you got sent to the principal's office
for yeah I remember I remember asking
about the seven I remember asking if
what the difference was between list
seven deadly sins and the Ten
Commandments and if they were in is it
and and why the seven days he spent
because I was I was honestly curious why
at the point in Exodus when the book of
Exodus when the Ten Commandments come up
in the seven deadly sins which I think
she wrote the seven deadly sins we had
already read enough chapters of the
Bible to see God commit four or five of
the seven deadly sins wrath jealousy
pride like those things at all those
things were all attributed to God and
then and I was and I was just asking
because I assume that there was I assume
that she knew the answer and that it had
been reconciled in some way so what was
the question why is it what's the
difference between and why is God
killing everybody because he's a proud
God and then and then the same time
telling us not that fries no Ted from
Jack I just think it seemed it's him
yeah I get it paradox yes I got it send
to the office I was in the office for a
couple hours they call my dad over from
the church he came over and they all fit
right i made a kiwi from they didn't
give me anything he joined in I think
you're going to be fine yeah I don't
think this is going to come up at the
rocket museum tomorrow no no no you know
was it you know why what isn't the first
word of it isn't the first word of the
rocketry museum the science and rafi
dream using the designs in the name that
is just a process you
but you can't talk about the Bible when
science is involved those things are
diametrically opposed this one or the
other well I think you can but that's
beyond the scope of this place only only
people who are confident in their faith
and actually believe what they say also
believe in science people who are
self-conscious about their faith in
things but they're people who are who
are people who are seen really afraid
it's all for [ __ ] really don't like
science because that could prove
ownership but it also but only if you're
of a mind to deny well I don't know
about that I don't know about that
people i don't know that i don't know
that all people of faith secretly
secretly believe that it might be or
[ __ ] i don't think i think the ones that
I think the ones that really believe in
it are okay with science I think if you
believe in God you can say i don't know
i think if you have faith you don't need
to prove it i think the most bonkers
thing is the creation museum that thing
is hilarious it is it is i would love to
go to that that's that's not on mistress
oh no no but we can go to that sometime
yeah that I know are from here is it
have you been there I've been there yeah
talk about faceless can't if you need to
you need to prove something if you need
to prove that Jesus wrestled a dinosaur
that dinosaur but yeah you're out of
your mind I tell you there's like I look
at this I go ahead a table do you have
any faith and this is the table you
don't could you see it yeah now if I
just told you I there was a table in my
room you would just have to believe me
tables existed yeah but then if you
would like if you're like I believe you
I've kind of resemble if there's a table
in your room but show me I don't believe
you believe me well I've heard a lot
about the table in your room chance and
I'd like to see it it's just like this
one you just got to believe in it you
just got to believe that I have it and i
will never show it you okay
which is believed but what I thing is
you know I know you know minimalist you
live in a room but now i'm at it now
what you're saying is what your thing is
you don't believe me so you want to see
it but what I'm saying is the creation
museum is for people who do believe me
but still are demanding to see it so you
can straight up say oh you're playing it
you really have safe you don't need to
see this yeah because it means you can't
see it and you believe in something you
can't see if you can see it you have no
faith you don't you don't need faith to
believe in the big bang theory is on TV
air I think that I think mostly the
reason people want to go to the creation
museum is because they can't believe
that there is a creation museum you
should go to the greasier museum there
is way less people there ironically than
you'd think well I think it would be
mostly comedians there any way I look
this has been fun if you want to hear us
talk more I feel like we kind of got a
little bug we got out of school we got a
little religious here at the end but do
you remember the advice you gave to
comedians people want to be comedians do
start doing comedy and don't stop doing
comedy which brings me to what I always
say every episode don't give up there
will be plenty of time to give up later
thank you for listening and thank you
for coming out on this tour to see Jeff
and I if you did if you didn't I hope to
see you soon at another place so go to
Jake discom there's still time to see is
in Nashville and or tell us where to eat
hot chicken thanks everybody
[Music]
machine please ok
Oh
[Music]
you heard that